l'euthanasie le débat relancé par la
sphère de mantes-la-jolie un acte
moralement irrecevable pour l'église
catholique mais des politiques réclament
un débat parlementaire cambodge première
élection libre vente organisée par le
pays depuis le génocide des khmers
rouges forte participation et la
sécurité comme enjeu d'un pays soumis à
la violence
le tour de france au pied des alpes
victoire au sprint à grenoble de
l'autrichien stuart o'grady jan ullrich
en jaune pour attaquer les alpes les
voix de la mère au festival de chants
marins de saint gilles croix de vie nous
embarquerons sur l'un des vieux
gréements
madame monsieur bonsoir pour un exploit
c'était bien un exploit louis blériot
chacun le sait avait été le premier
aviateur à franchir la manche en avion
en 1909 son petit fils qui porte le même
prénom en étaient réduits à faire ce
constat après avoir échoué 99 ans plus
tard dans la même tentative son avion un
frêle aéroplan de bois et de toile
identique à celui de 1909 s'est abîmé ce
matin dans un étang moins d'une minute
après le décollage
récit d'une brève aventure alban milk
aussi à tous ceux qui pensent que
l'histoire est un perpétuel
recommencement les images qui suivent en
apporter un qu elles démentent
voici les aventures aéronautique de
louis blériot petit fils de louis
blériot à bord de son frêle aéroplan de
bois et de toile
il s'élance yeah man vers 6h ce matin
pour traverser la manche comme le fit
jadis son aïeul
là je vous parle d'un temps que les
moins de 100 ans ne peuvent pas
connaître
c'était le 25 juillet 1909 louis blériot
l'autre donc avait décollé de cette même
prairies et atteint l'angleterre au
dessus de douvres après 30 minutes de
traversée ce matin force est de
constater que le vol
ce fut un peu plus brefs
à peine plus d'une minute et un
amerrissage pas réussi dans un étang
voisin le héros n'est pas blessé et
l'aéronef a pu être ramené à terre j'ai
commencé à gérer
je répondais pas normalement et puis
plus corrigé dans un sens et pluies
continuelles s'embarquer dans un sens
opposé
et puis bon voile
louis blériot l'actuel a donc bien
renouer avec l'esprit de ces merveilleux
fous volants sur leurs drôles de
machines
l'important alors était de décoller pas
d'intérêt la sphère d'euthanasie de
mantes-la-jolie on a appris aujourd'hui
que l'infirmière mise en examen avait
été fortement choquées auparavant pour
avoir assisté au meurtre par arme à feu
d'une malade de 76 ans par son mari et
cela en plein service
aujourd'hui le débat sur l'euthanasie
est relancé sur ce plateau hier bernard
kouchner appelaient à se garder de tout
jugement moral hâtif
d'autant que cette question très
sensible est appréhendée de façon
différente selon les pays
aujourd'hui l'église catholique rappelle
que l'euthanasie est moralement il
recevable mais refuse cependant
l'acharnement thérapeutique chez les
politiques certains réclament un débat
parlementaire d'autre qu'une législation
soit mise en place
eric bastions dans les chambres de cet
hôpital
une jeune infirmière a aidé à mourir une
trentaine de malades incurables
l'euthanasie est de nouveau en question
au sein de la société française sur ce
sujet la position de l'hôpital est clair
plutôt qu'une telle demande n'a pas à
cet égard des tables il ya le quoi
devenir autour de j il ya les valeurs du
personnel soignant qui via les
obligations du code pénal
mais derrière la sphère de
mantes-la-jolie provoquer des réactions
l'euthanasie est un problème moral qui
repose sur le corps médical pour les
médecins souvent la mort est un échec
mais la mort c'est la fin de ma vie de
saluer les gens que l'on connaît et il
faut la préparer ce passage doit être
accompagnée médicalement le mieux
possible nous avons 20 andro tard là
dessus dans le code pénal le mot nazi
n'existe pas au parlement un projet de
loi avait été déposée par le sénateur
cayavé en 1976 mais rejeter
pour certains il est temps aujourd'hui
de poser les vraies questions
il faut que le parlement vote une loi
sur ce très important sujet cette loi à
mon avis devrait reposer sur deux
éléments
le premier c'est le consentement
absolument sûr du malade ou de sa
famille et le second c'est une prise de
décision qui interviendrait avec le
malade ou sa famille
un ou deux médecins et un magistrat une
position que ne partagent ni le conseil
de l'ordre des médecins
ni l'église catholique de france ils
sont tous deux pour les soins palliatifs
mais contre l'euthanasie légiférer sur
ce sujet ça voudrait dire qu'on
reconnaît que c'est un moyen normal de
mettre fin à ses jours ce qui est
absolument inadmissible en australie
neuf mois après son adoption par le
parlement
la première et seule loi au monde
autorisant l'euthanasie a été invalidée
plus près de nous au pays bas un médecin
peut provoquer la mort d'un malade mais
sous conditions et seulement s'il a
exprimé à maintes reprises sa volonté
d'en finir
une décision qui ne peut en tout état de
cause jamais se prendre seul le naufrage
de perros guirec une chapelle ardente a
été dressée dans l'église intégristes de
la fraternité saint-pie 10 à
mantes-la-jolie des corps de deux des
quatre scouts morts noyés et reposent
leurs parents demandent la libération de
l'abbé cottard responsable du camp de
vacances actuellement incarcéré à la
prison de saint brieuc il souhaite que
le prêtre célèbre mardi
les obsèques de leur sang alerte à la
méningite dans un camping du pas de
calais un enfant britannique qui venait
d'y séjourner est décédé d'une méningite
des méningites du type c'est rare et
foudroyante 76 enfants présents dans ce
camping près de boulogne-sur-mer ont été
vaccinées l'autoroute de la côte basque
est toujours bloqué des centaines de
poids lourds devront patienter encore
quelques heures avant de pouvoir passer
la frontière espagnole qui leur est
interdite pour cause de festivités de
saint-jacques et déviations sont en
place pour les automobilistes
pascal golomer plusieurs centaines de
poids lourds bloqués sur l'autoroute
menant à la frontière franco espagnole
c'est exactement ce que redoutaient les
autorités pour ce week end des poids
lourds qui ont littéralement prise au
piège les automobilistes condamnés à
prendre leur mal en patience
il ose alors qu'on attend traverser la
frontière et vous avez été bloqués
parfois pape a évoqué bien sûr parce
qu'ils soient des ondes ya un problème
avec la les basques il ne laisse pas
passer de routiers donc le gouvernement
autonome basque espagnol avait
effectivement interdit la circulation
des camions en raison de la fête de la
saint-jacques les français avait donc
annoncé depuis plusieurs jours la
fermeture de la frontière mais les
routiers ont été victime semble-t-il de
la rumeur le problème s'est produit vers
17 heures 18 heures ou sur la foi d'un
message non vérifiées jeter lancé sur la
sib il n'est pas lourd
il a été cru que la fois la police
autonome basque
ouvrez la frontière de 20 heures à 22
heures donc tous les poids lourds sont
espagnols et où autant se sont rués pour
essayer de profiter de ce créneau là et
sont trouvés dans une masse puisque la
frontière est restée fermée du côté
autonome basque
les voitures bloquées ont été dégagés au
cours de la nuit mais l'autoroute est
restée fermée entre saint jean de luz et
la frontière de quoi provoquer quelques
beaux embouteillages les poids lourds
devraient pouvoir franchir à nouveau la
frontière à partir de minuit mais la
circulation ne redeviendra tout à fait
normal qu'au petit matin niveau de
niveau 2 de pollution atteint dans les
bouches-du-rhône chaleur vent faible et
circulation ont fait grimper l'ozone les
activités physiques intenses et
l'utilisation des voitures sont vivement
déconseillé le président chirac aux
côtés des soldats du feu il assistera
demain à brignoles dans le var à une
démonstration des moyens de prévention
et de lutte contre les incendies
parmi tous ceux qui participent il ya
les sentinelles du feu des guetteurs
installés sur les points les plus hauts
du relief et qui donne l'alertent dès
qu'une fumée suspect est décelée olivier
théron et didier beaumont reportage s'il
est midi au soleil l'heure la plus
chaude de la journée l'heure où les
cigales sont heureuses l'heure de tous
les dangers
gilbert est à l'affût les yeux dans les
jumelles il observe la forêt ça fait 16
ans chaque été pompier volontaire il
remonte dans sa tour au sommet du mont
vinaigre 618 m d'altitude au milieu de
l'estérel et il attend avec un taux
d'humidité très faible et de fortes
chaleurs la moindre étincelle peut être
fatale
pour plusieurs hectares de forêt alors
même pas le temps de manger
certainement mais je crois que c'est une
bonne bonne chose dans le dans le sens
on est concentré à fond sur ce qu'on
fait c'est géré en un peu comme comme un
militaire en campagne on est présent sur
son champ de bataille en permanence
soudain dans le calme de l'après midi
celle alerte un léger panache de fumée à
côté d'un lotissement
pour gilbert c'est la guerre qui
commence
ils repèrent la position définie le type
d' incendies et alerte le centre
opérationnel du var à draguignan de
parler au codis on fait confiance aux
guetteurs et à leur expérience ils sont
équipés en jumelles en moyens de
transmission pour déceler les fouilles à
voir ou bien bien dire si ce sont bien
définis concernant un feu ils n'ont pas
autre chose on écobuage que diaconu
validé en définitive
l'intervention immédiatement le
dispositif se met en place des
patrouilles à moto vont sur les lieux
d'un incendie suivi de très près par des
véhicules d'intervention
en quelques minutes grâce à gilbert le
feu sera maîtrisée s'il est dans les
premières minutes on a le bon dosage de
moyens qui vont arriver sur les lieux
dans un temps relativement court
on a la chance de gagner ce combat
puis la journée reprend son cours
tranquille le risque diminue avec le
soleil mais gilbert ne relâche pas sa
surveillance les pyromanes attaques
souvent en fin d'après midi
enfin la nuit tombe l'apocalypse n'était
pas pour aujourd'hui
mais l'été est encore long
le tour de france au pied des alpes et
l'australien stuart o'grady ancien
maillot jaune a pris la bonne échappée
au 42e km il a réglé au sprint un sprint
houleux à grenoble ses cinq compagnons
jan ullrich abordera les sommets en
leader alexandre kara nathalie gallet un
dimanche à la campagne un petit air de
promenade pour les hommes du tour
l'allemand jan ullrich de l'équipe
deutsche telekom le roi du tour 97 fait
du tourisme
geagea premier numéro un français numéro
un mondial fait la causette sur le tour
on s'économise al'approche des alpes 186
km sous un soleil de plomb c'est vrai ça
donne soif avec ou sans casquette
ça ressemble bien la montagne mais ce
n'est pas encore la montagne dans le
vercors cet après midi il y à des hommes
qui ont résisté
pour ces six là c'est la grande évasion
o'grady calcaterra rodriguez vent debout
mein herr nine scène et laurent desbiens
la belle échappée ira jusqu'à son terme
jusqu'à l'arrivée à grenoble la porte
des alpes
c'est l'australien o'grady déjà maillot
jaune pendant trois jours de cholet à
brive qui remporte le sprint final
calcaterra dans un premier temps second
est rétrogradé pour sprint irrégulier
résultats rodriguez le seul portugais du
peloton et deuxième vente dont les
néerlandais 3e laurent desbiens le
français 5e au classement général ulrich
conserve le maillot jaune devant bobby
lulic et laurent jalabert
demain c'est sur la montagne sera belle
mais impitoyable aussi avec le col du
galibier
ce sera le sommet du tour le tour de
france qui a retrouvé un peu de sérénité
quelle est l'ambiance chez les milliers
de spectateurs toujours massés tout au
long du parcours nathalie moisan marco
pantani poursuivi par ses fans jusque
dans son quart avant le départ ce matin
à valréas
jalabert applaudi par son public non
seulement le spectateur n'a rien perdu
de son enthousiasme mais il s'est trouvé
de nouveaux héros les leaders de la
fronde contre les médias plus populaire
que jamais le public comme les coureurs
souhaitent qu'on parle moi ni de pages
et un peu plus de la course
il faut continuer dans la course et puis
c'est fini pour arrêter d'en parler
c'est fini on en a trop parlé mais il
faut continuer d'ailleurs c'est le sport
qui prime c'est tout les affaires de
dopage doivent se régler après la fin du
tour mais peut-être me sens mal pour un
bien
un moyen d'assainir le cyclisme parce
qu'on peut s'avérer situation et qui à
la limite c'est très bien pour les
coureurs justement de faux papiers et à
leur santé
je pense que dans les autres zones et
ben les vitesses sont moins élevés puis
c'est tout on reviendra dès des choses
plus humaine car c'était une bonne chose
qui arrive tout à fait je pense pour
tous le cyclisme n'est pas le seul sport
vendredi par le dopage
dès lors pourquoi ç'a payé le tour seuls
les tricheurs doivent être sanctionnés
et tant pis si la compétition perd un
peu de son sel quand même un peu le ce
qu'on dirait chez nous en afrique le
piment de la chose mais il ya aussi la
loi du sport
la curie il faut condamner à grenoble
sur les derniers kilomètres de l'étape
comme tous les jours la foule était
nombreuse
preuve s'il en fallait que les affaires
de dopage n'ont pas entamé la popularité
de la plus grande des courses cyclistes
et puis au fil des jours les langues se
délient justement sur ces affaires de
dopage dans un hebdomadaire suisse le
coureur de l'équipe festina armin meier
qui a reconnu s'être dopé assure qu'une
centaine de coureurs pourraient être
mises en cause après le tour de france
son coéquipier alex auld a présenté ses
excuses à ses fans tout en assumant
comme une décision personnelle
la prise de dopants il revient également
sur ses difficiles conditions de
détention nous l'écoutons
ailleurs c'est vrai qu'elle entend
wiimote mg admis devant les enquêteurs
avoir pris de le paix avec nous alors
qu'est ce que le pm c'est pas le
problème
le pays est sur la liste des produits
dopants donc c'est interdit je concède
que j'ai commis une infraction mais la
caféine est aussi sur la liste des
produits interdits
je bois du café du matin au soir mais
personne ne m'a jamais contrôlé positif
au café la nuit a été longue longue
interminable
pendant cette nuit j'ai entendu les
autres crier dans les autres bureaux
j'ai même entendu richard virenque
criait et je crois qu'aucun homme ne
peut rester insensible à de telles
pressions oui oui j'ai aussi dit que
j'allais arrêter le vélo c'est quand
j'ai peut-être eu tort
c'était une réaction à chaud je vais
laisser passer du temps il repensait à
tête reposée j'ai toujours espéré sert
une belle carrière et je vais donc bien
réfléchir
alex ou le parle aujourd'hui avec
franchise à de nombreux médias il
affirme regretter ses mensonges du début
et explique qu'il était pris dans un
système un système selon lui connue de
tous coureurs dirigeants sportifs
organisateurs
fonctionnaires et journalistes aimé
jacquet fêtés en héros c'est en haute
savoie sa deuxième patrie les habitants
de tonnes où il passe ses vacances
depuis une trentaine d'années lui
réserve en ce moment même un accueil
triomphal à la hauteur de l'exploit du
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
championne du monde de football virginie
fichés et olivier jacquelin sont de la
fête
une fois encore la magie des bleus au
père la foule s'est massée le rêve peut
recommencer
grisant ici aimé jacquet on le connaît
bien et milou le premier il se souvient
de ce jeune homme timide qui arriva pour
la première fois en 63 7 à la fin de son
service militaire il avait trouvé un ami
de tonnes qui lui avait conseillé le
petit chalet des est ouvert le destin a
voulu que milou habite aujourd'hui ce
petit chalet berceau d'une longue amitié
car depuis aînés est devenu comme un
enfant du pays pour ses amis le succès
du sélectionneur ne supplantera jamais
les souvenirs entre copains avec les
jackets ce sont les sorties en montagne
bien sûr je passe devant pour régler le
pain jeu mentalement parce que je
n'arriverai jamais à suivre ici commence
l'autre domaine d'aimé jacquet le petit
stade de thoune ou jeune joueur il
s'entraînait à loisir grâce à milou
justement alors président du club de
football local
trente cinq ans plus tard et mais n'a
pas oublié le cadeau et c'est un autre
stade qu'il a offert à son vieil ami
il m'a fait déjà participé à la finale
de la coupe du monde en étant reçus
spécialement à clairefontaine pour y
dormir et dîner et
déjeuner avec les joueurs de l'équipe de
france c'est le plus beau cadeau qu'il
ait pu le faire mais aujourd'hui atone
et les jacks et n'appartenait plus à
sézanne y quinze jours après la victoire
la fièvre n'est pas retombée mémé
jacquet ne se laisse pas emporter son
message est clair je leur dire
maintenant - c'est fini il faudra me
laisser tomber
eh bien il faudra penser qu'à cette
coupe du monde cette coupe du monde
c'est la coupe du monde la france
et moi je vais me retirer tranquillement
et je vais me refaire des forces et je
vais penser à autre chose
heureux ému mais déterminé l'entraîneur
raccroche ses crampons désormais ils
n'aspirent qu'à une chose des vacances
bien méritées à l'étranger au cambodge
plus de 5 millions d'électeurs étaient
appelés aujourd'hui à renouveler
l'assemblée nationale la participation
semble très forte dès les premières
heures des centaines d'électeurs faisait
patiemment la queue devant les bureaux
les anciens communistes du chef de
gouvernement ou une scène affronter les
deux chefs de l'opposition le prince
ranariddh des l'ancien ministre des
finances
les clés du scrutin maryse burgot dans
les sacs bleus les urnes de la
réconciliation transporté sous bonne
escorte
ils sont la fierté du peuple cambodgien
car pour la première fois depuis 30 ans
ce pays aujourd'hui presque pacifié est
capable d'organiser lui-même des
élections législatives en ce dimanche de
vote
90 % des électeurs se sont donc est
littéralement précipiter pour accomplir
leur devoir de citoyen phnom penh qui
semble aujourd'hui retrouvé un début de
sourire après les années noires de la
dictature khmers rouges
les résultats ne seront pas connus avant
une semaine
mais l'on sait des
que le futur premier ministre sera l'un
de ces trois hommes le premier s'appelle
en scène il est l'actuel premier
ministre communiste fils de paysan et ex
khmers rouges il se targue aujourd'hui
d'avoir pacifié le pays
en obtenant la reddition de la
résistance cnef le deuxième homme n'est
pas fils de paysan né fils de roi le
prince ranariddh est d'ailleurs vénéré
comme l'est son père le roi sihanouk
écarté du pouvoir il ya un an par une
scène ce royaliste espère aujourd'hui
prendre sa revanche
le troisième homme est un brillant
intellectuel ex ministre des finances
fois - ci portent les espoirs d'une
jeunesse éduquée hélas dès 20 ans
d'autocratie incarné par une femme
principal enjeu de ce scrutin
reconstruire un état de droit dans un
pays où la violence est quotidienne
après 30 ans de guerre sur place jean
marc il use et dominique merlet appel
anonyme pour blessures par balles au
samu installés par la croix rouge
française rappelle les débuts de soirées
ressent trop souvent à cela
direction rue des petites fleurs dans un
quartier chaud de la capitale
cambodgienne aux policiers déjà sur
place la foule a expliqué que la victime
a été je cite tiré en pleine rue par
trois hommes à moto
il s'est écoulé vingt minutes à peine
est alarmant explique le médecin
la victime est très grièvement atteinte
à la tête est-ce que ça arrive souvent
des scènes comme celle ci l'enquêté
policière établira que la victime 27 ans
employé au ministère des finances avait
été abattu à la suite d'une rixe
une balle de 4 54 anne automatique bon
marché
vendetta tous les jours à la une des
journaux de phnom penh l'héritage
violent de 30 ans de guerre ici deux
voleurs abattu par les policiers après
une course poursuite
là un homme a tué pour sa moto et puis
ces grenades non explosées lancé sur le
domicile du ministre de la justice
règlement de compte politique criminelle
ou personnel saura-t-on jamais pourquoi
est morte cannes
cette mère de famille c'était un soir de
juillet comme cette famille et chaîne et
son mari avaient emmené les enfants
manège en inconnus à moto avaient lancé
une grenade avant de disparaître
bilan un mort et neuf blessés
querelle de forains ou geste de
déséquilibrer pour son journal d'une
sereine enquêter sur place ont trouvé
deux pistes
la police n'a pas encore pour évaluer
copé ce soir mais la plupart des gens
pensent que c'est politique
les cambodgiens oui depuis presque
trente ans dans l'environnement vision
la wii des conflits dans ce pays et des
pays voisins et ils sont bouleversés un
traumatisé c'est paris wable il faut
changer
alors une fois n'est pas coutume à la
veille du vote les bonzes ir victimes
par billy du génocide khmer rouge sont
descendus dans la rue pour parler non
violence
un terrain sur lequel les principaux
candidats ne les ont soutenus et de loin
al'inverse du vietnam le gaullisme
cambodgien n'a jamais été une véritable
force politique
aujourd'hui encore ces ressources
restent bien dérisoire comparée à celle
des trois principaux partis politiques
cambodgien mais les moines bouddhistes
cambodgien veulent croire que pas à pas
ils pourront aider leur société à
retrouver les repères perdus d'une
véritable paix civile la longue litanie
des massacres en algérie vingt personnes
ont encore été égorgé la nuit dernière
par des islamistes armés dans deux
villages proches de tlemcen et de saïda
à l'ouest d'alger poursuite de
l'offensive cerveau kosovo
l'intervention de l'armée fédérale
contre les séparatistes kosovars a fait
de nouvelles victimes et provoque
l'exode de milliers de personnes
isabelle steiss les forces serbes
pilonnent les positions des séparatistes
albania comme ici à ce bench lui c'est
qu'à contrôler la plupart des villages
situés en zone rurale au kosovo
de violents combats qui depuis vendredi
embrase le centre de la province
cette fois ci c'est une vaste offensive
de l'armée yougoslave objectif dé
bloquer les axes routiers reliant la
capitale pristina aux deux autres
principales villes du pays
car si les serbes restent maîtres des
villes les routes elles sont coupées par
les séparatistes albanais depuis
plusieurs mois forte d'un potentiel
militaire renforcée l'armée yougoslave
cherche à affaiblir davantage lui ces
cas qui a déjà perdu 110 hommes la
semaine dernière dans une embuscade à la
frontière albanaise des combats qui
jette une nouvelle fois des milliers de
civils sur les routes et qui entame
chaque jour un peu plus l'espoir de
trouver une solution de thé les sports
avec le tennis cinq victoires à zéro la
coupe de la fédération est pleine pour
les suissesses est désespérément vide
pour les filles de la bande à noah
malgré la résistance héroïque d'amélie
mauresmo face à la numéro 1 mondiale
martina hingis cédric beaudou est encore
sous le charme
après deux défaites française amélie
mauresmo est le dernier espoir de
l'équipe de france dans cette coupe de
la fédération
à 19 ans la française 34e joueuse
mondiale et championne du monde junior
doit absolument battre martin n 10 pour
espérer qualifier son équipe
un défi à la porte et d'amélie mauresmo
qui sans complexe remporte la première
manche au jeu décisif face à la numéro
un mondiale
mais voilà mené 4 jeux à 1 dans le
deuxième set
martina hingis inflige sept jeux
consécutifs à la française ait remporté
finalement cette rencontre en trois
manches 6-7 6-4 6-2 je suis déçu mais
c'est
il écarte tout ça
revirement
et un et deux et trois zéro c'est le
type de l'été mais cette fois c'est au
tour des suisses de chanter les
françaises tenant du titre 5 mm50 sans
même sauvé l'honneur formule 1 mika
hakkinen retrouve la gagne au volant de
sa mclaren mercedes il a fait la course
en tête du grand prix d'autriche et l'a
emporté devant son coéquipier david
coulthard et l'allemand michael
schumacher laurent frédéric bollée pour
les bolides au pays de mozart grande
musique pour grand vainqueur en
l'occurrence mika hakkinen
copé une mozart chorale sur le podium
pour célébrer les princes où les fous du
volant car dès le départ on se demande à
qui nen parti de la troisième position
est certes déjà en tête mais derrière ça
se gâte une voiture qui part en toupie
et ça fait du grabuge quatre concurrents
qui restent sur le carreau et bientôt
deux eaux au deuxième virage
cette fois entre coéquipiers les esprits
sont donc chaud et ils vont le rester
akin end devant schumacher derrière
c'est enfin le duel au sommet entre les
deux leaders au championnat du monde
superbe passe d'armes qui ne se conclut
pas comme on pouvait le croire
schumacher a échoué schumacher a cédé à
kinnen pour un temps reprend donc sa
chevauchée fantastique sur l'ancien
circuit de zeltweg rebaptisé spielberg
le finlandais ne fait pas de cinéma il
assure solide à la recherche de sa
première victoire depuis deux mois
schumacher néanmoins est revenu dans son
sillage et voici bientôt le deuxième
épisode de leur affrontement
nous sommes au 16e tour quand soudain
incroyable cabriole de l'allemand qui a
dû se faire très peur en tout cas
schumacher peut repartir mais la
victoire pour lui s'est envolé autres
faits de course
alesi et fisichella s'accroche bêtement
la responsabilité de l'italien est
engagée mauvais scénario pour les deux
héros des essais retour sur schumacher
qui revient en 3e position son
coéquipier heures bein sachant toujours
sacrifié tout le monde peut donc être
content schumacher qui sauve qu'à points
précieux et madame à kinnen qui voit son
mari empocher la sixième victoire de sa
carrière la cinquième cette saison au
championnat aquitaine devance maintenant
schumacher 2000 points de quoi en perdre
presque la tête
notre tournée des spectacles et des
festivals d'été avec ce soir l'été
girondins près de 50 événements
différents parmi eux une exposition de
sculptures qui se tient depuis six ans
dans la petite commune d'abzac éric
perrin et sébastien de lalo nous y
invite
la sculpture dans tous ses ébats les
artistes au travail au coeur de la cité
depuis six ans abzac petite commune de
gironde de 1500 habitants offrent un
festival de sculptures attachant et
étonnant
il ne va pas du tout habitude de voir ça
on travaille donc ça me permet de courir
jusqu'au 16 août
la maternelle le centre culturel et même
l'église se transforme en lieu
d'exposition
pas question pour autant de changer les
habitudes de vie aujourd'hui ces
mariages à abzac c'est petit endroit il
ya une concentration d'oeuvres de
qualité d'abord et puis surtout qui soit
pas relégué dans un endroit à part c'est
dans 12 endroits concret c'est partagé
par tout le monde de dire que c'est pas
y'a pas une démarche particulière à
faire pour aller est-ce que tu reviens
vers les gens des ateliers pour toucher
palper frappé imaginer réaliser son
n'est pas compte des difficultés que
c'était donc tu regarde différemment les
autres oeuvrent maintenant au fil des
ans à brac s'est taillé une réputation
de découvreur de talents les acheteurs
européens commencent même à venir faire
ici leur marché automnal
plus de 150 oeuvres sont présentées du
figuratif à l'avant-garde contemporaine
entrée gratuite les organisateurs
cherchent à toucher tous les publics
de l'audace sans élitisme c'est dire aux
grandes villes aussi un petit peu lisse
passe quelque chose ailleurs quoi tout
simplement ça ne se passe pas qu'à paris
la culture sinon pas qu'à bordeaux il ya
des endroits où il ya des gens qui ont
de la volonté du dynamisme et qui
veulent essayer d'avoir des artistes de
talent et du talent abzac en a les rives
du canal de lille se sont offertes aux
créateurs
on appelle cela du land art dollar en
pleine nature
le tourisme fluvial devient tourisme
culturel dernier pied de nez d'une
petite commune aux grands musées
nationaux
et si vous préférez la musique ne
négligez pas la grosse caisse ou plus
exactement les tambours du japon kodo le
plus grand groupe de percussions du pays
du soleil levant a réussi le mariage
entre musique traditionnelle et moderne
on dit même que cela aide les enfants à
s'endormir mais oui kodo au festival de
nyon en suisse avec olivier linosa et
frédéric bazille
des artistes qui transforme le vacarme
en musique des athlètes qui se bat avec
des tambours une chorégraphie de
l'énergie et du rythme imaginé par coup
d'eau le plus grand groupe de
percussions japonais
ce match qu'on sait c'est une chose
magique qu intel sont qu un tel vacarme
comme disent certains ramènent des
enfants à s'endormir
des enfants qui s'endorment qui se
laisse aller bercé par la respiration
d'un tambour géant de 500 kg dont le
rythme épouse les battements du coeur
amusé cayzac robinet si on n'a pas fait
les comptes m notre musique est un
mariage entre musiques traditionnelles
et musiques modernes nos compositions
sont un mélange d'influencés venus
d'europe et d'occident et même d'afrique
les musiciens de pau d'eaux-vives
retirer en communauté sur une petite île
du japon créée en 1981 la troupe a déjà
donné de 2000 concerts un long voyage
un long périple poétique à travers le
monde à travers le temps
faire revivre les chants de marins qui
s'était perdue avec la fin de la marine
à voile c'est l'objet du festival de
saint gilles croix de vie en vendée les
marins d'une vingtaine de navires s'y
sont retrouvés ce week-end frédéric
renoux et manu ribeiro ont embarqué sur
l'un de ces vieux gréements la
brigantine appareils
d'abord une complainte comme autant que
les matelots qui étaient les leurs pour
les longues campagnes de pêche et déjà
il faut hisser les voiles assemblée son
courage et entonner les chants de
manoeuvre mélodies venues de l'époque où
l'on navigue et en chanson c'est parfait
pour l'amour du bel canto fait c'est
fait pour aider à la manoeuvre
ça sert à plusieurs choses d'une part
c'est pour coordonner les efforts de
tout l'équipage et d'autre part c'est
pour effacer la notion de temps et pour
éviter que les gens s'ennuient et les
pauses qu'on le maître d'équipage qui
disait il en sait la chanson pour
coordonner ces sommes c'est lui qui
choisit c'est hélas le posco par un cri
ou par un espèce d'appel à la manoeuvre
un crime que je veux pas lancer leur
affaire
et puis ben les enfants se calquer
dessus en fonction du rythme que le
chanteur va donner
manoeuvrer et ramener la brigantine à
bon port sur les côtes de vendée pour
partager avec ceux qui restent à terre
ses chansons qui l'ont sauvée de l'oubli
ses mélodies ont failli disparaître avec
la fin des vieux gréements ils les ont
sauvés après des années de patientes
collecte auprès d'anciens matelots
aujourd'hui ces chants forge l'âme du
festival de saint gilles et déjà il faut
reprendre le large
bercé par le chant de john comme au
temps où la mère était une aventure au
long cours
musique encore it's only rock and roll
80000 spectateurs trois générations de
fans ont vibré hier au stade de france
avec les rolling stones mick jagger qui
fête aujourd'hui ses 55 ans était au
mieux de sa forme silhouette sourire et
coupe de cheveux inchangé tous les
grands classiques ont été revisités
cette effraction painting blague brunch
au coeur et out of control qu'on entend
actuellement
aïe
et
maintenant
on ne s'en lassera jamais c'est la fin
de ce journal je vous en rappelle les
principaux titres l'euthanasie le débat
relancé par la sphère de mantes-la-jolie
un acte moralement irrecevable pour
l'église catholique mais des politiques
réclament un débat parlementaire le
cambodge première élection libre vente
organisée par le pays depuis le génocide
des khmers rouges forte participation et
la sécurité comme enjeu d'un pays soumis
à la violence dans un instant la météo
d'isabel martinez ont des eaux nord
orage au sud sauf sur la méditerranée il
fera très beau demain 20h vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian bonne soirée
sur france 2
oh